notre monde c'est squeeze aujourd'hui ce
trouble de l fois c'est aussi vallery et
rares sont les combattants aussi pardon
et rares sont les combattants aussi
blasés que alors qu' on va prendre
est-ce qu'on ne prendrait pas de petit
pirate adoré un âge et envie d'en faire
une vidéo sur ce jeu puisque je le
trouve vraiment marrant surtout quand tu
sors ton pistolet que tu fais pas comme
ça et tu rates le mec ou non mais c'est
une blague
il va bien viens on t'attend bas on
t'attendait j'ai dit regardez l'oréal et
de faire la technique du contournement
au pl oui maman
hop là ok mais alors là on sent qu'on a
déjà fait des vidéos là dessus non ça se
sent les duels étaient engagés musique
de cobayes bat trop tard pour la musique
y est c'était sympa en début de partie
ça me plaît beaucoup
ça nous plaît beaucoup alors on y
retourne aulas tu vas mettant mes belge
apparaît qu elle laisse moi tranquille
deux secondes ogives et je m'en bats les
steaks j'y vais comme ça allez tu m'as
raté non eh ben ça finit toujours en
brochettes toute manière des histoires
comme ça boume là dans l'omoplate gauche
donnez moi j'adore quand il ya un duel
entre deux mecs comme la et j'arrive et
je fais mon jeu court comme on a chaud
tour d'un cas nous tu ne m'as jamais je
suis caché parmi les fougères mais
oubliée au nom allez allez allez hop je
vous amener non voilà ça c'est ma
technique de fourbe les deux sont vus ce
combat tout moi je recherche
tranquillement contact à côté comme ça
et d'un coup et je rate au plat
attendait mais au nom lui a non allaités
toit aux plats qu'ils qu'est ce qui se
passe je crois que je crains les lens
n'ont par contre il me fait peur à
avancer en dansant comme ça je sentais
pas dès le début on va partir sur ma
déjà non mais toi tu es notre copain de
tout à l'heure mon gars et bah oui eh
ben ça se voit d'ailleurs un cette rage
dans cette veine
enfin dans tes veines stack une veine tu
es mort hop là et on est bon un mois je
trouve qu'on a un petit niveau quand
même un petit petit petit petit niveau
un micro niveau voire même un âne haut
niveau on est apparue où l'a1 à côté
d'un coffre alors déjà on va prendre 5
euros et valeo grec n'a pas de bouclier
tu vas regretter bon c'est quand je suis
quelqu'un et que ce pistolet [ __ ] ils
croient ils croient que je vis de mec à
droite 1 et la faune au plat et là il se
dira je vais te tuer et non technique
fougères mon gars qu'est ce que tu fais
elle libère un
port qui endort un normalement tu dois
dormir ça n'a pas trop marché était
peut-être un peu trop viril le ninja qui
s'enflamme attendez attendez
s'il vous plaît déjà vous arrêtez de
nous battre il se présente moi je moi je
savais pas rien c'est pas parce que
j'étais sauvé que je vais pas tué je
suis rica de la lumière
regardez battle de chirico est
maintenant bassi à l'erea pas rire et
apparaît jeune ninja tu ne peux pas
mourir comme ça sur le champ de bataille
je refuse un samouraï avec un arc
oui hop ok la flèche dampier très utile
ah non je m'en vais or fou je suis le
pire du mec peu fair-play bon j'arrête
ok battle engagé sais pas qui je suis
moi moi j'ai été formé par par personne
ait eu la vie ce nom et patronat à
settat pro alors tu me dire petit mon
gars tu as l'air occupé
moi aussi je l'étais partie non mais
pourquoi quatre contrats pros vous y
êtes
regardez top 20 ce qui s'entretuent et
moi j'avais par derrière de samouraï
experts il a réussi à mettre entre les
deux courbes haut ce qu'il a fait c'est
beau aussi rouler dans le sable comme ça
attentes autant n'ont quà ménages de
transe les moeurs ouais ouais je préfère
oui s'il te plait je te regarde même
j'hallucine ceci est un détournement de
pamiers mais je les touche et une à moi
non non je l'avais touché c'est bien
comme ça il était affaibli
je l'entendais même dire viens de tuer
hachette vient y vient comme ça mais est
ce qu'un jour ce pistolet bâtir autre
chose que des flèches en mousse savez ça
comment j'ai tué faut absolument qu'on
passe niveau 3 ou morale gros fusil
d'assaut au bras on pourra braquer des
palais par exemple au elle était belle
moore est tout ce qu ils doivent en ces
mois
pas tant que ça ait fait du 2 kills une
mort ratio de 2 c'est pas mal je propose
sont qui la partie maintenant pourquoi
sur une belle feinte arrête de [ __ ]
mais murray arrête de crier bordel vert
et tétouan
tais toi tu te tais [ __ ] a au nom fait
quoi toi ben voilà on épie poule mais
les flammes de l'ombre à temps mais bon
ça me fait kiffer 300 fois c'est pas un
simple c'est un briquet j'aimerais bien
un jour
tapez de loin comme ça bon après je dis
ça mon pistolet tient 8000 mètres donc
bon on voit bien je me colle à lui
surtout oh non ça marche tu as pris cher
regardez le regarde et on fait ouais on
va l'attendre là c'est que ça a marché
jusqu'à j'ai entendu j'ai entendu plein
de tours aux plats aux tous premiers
duels qu'on gagne 1 c'est pas mal hop là
un petit coin ni vu ni connu
vas-y bien là bien là vas-y bien la fois
plein deuxième petit coup au plein au
plat à je me suis enflammé la lettre au
dos plat je vais juste faire ça jusqu'à
ce que je récupère ma vie hopla dégage m
combat voilà ça on reprend irene qui
arrivait voilà bien la regarder le
regarder le larbre aller retour d un
tronc d'arbre
je fais quoi là non mais tu vois quand
même pas que tu va me tuer mon gars eh
ben attends tu vois quand même pas comme
tu es mon gars tiens mon gars tu es mon
gars et si je joue à la hache c'est ça
marche mais attendez c'est un marteau tu
crois que tu ai pas vus et ben là là je
peux plus de voir par contre
oh ça fait mal tu fais quoi
mais tu connais pas match tu as tu
connaîtras jamais vu que tu m'as tu es
allé au doigt et le deuxième il est ami
donc je lâche la tête là aller 2 2 j'ai
toujours rêvé d'être un pirate a pas
esquivé tu vas décédé et et et été ni ma
mère ni mon père ni ma soeur ouais label
choucha propre
c'était le moment qui m'a rendu heureux
dans cette partie excusez-moi intervient
dans votre édition combat j'aimerais
s'il vous plaît déjà à tuer lui parle xp
voilà parfait merci beaucoup et mourir
il ya pas de problème on a le fusil au
c'est violent mme à ça c'est pas c'est
pas deux amis voilà n'en ait eu coup pep
alarme scoop et moi là en fait d'accord
ok là si on meurt au maire pour de bon
voilà je suis tendu a gelé vas-y tu mets
un coup il meurt sauté dessus
oui allez voir au courant c'est pas pour
rien mon gars non non regardez rennes
ces petits trous la 2e place à qui je
t'embauche mon gars qu'est ce qui se
passe tu vas mourir et je m'en fous juge
lui ai offert mon corps
calme-toi les morts calme-toi calme-toi
occulte un mois plus tôt ce qu'est ce
qui se passe va se faire au nom c'était
un combat d'hommes torse nu a pas
d'enjeu pas torse nu maintenant j'ai
envie je suis assez en poids sont
attendus dont on en a marre de toi ça
suffit poti hop la voile a offert ce
poisson allez allez au c'est beau je
m'assois sur vous et j'arrête la vidéo i
see what bouclier je fais toi monsieur
faut laisser les virils entrera on vous
a dit laisser les clés d'entre eux c'est
pas vrai [ __ ] la fin laisse moi [ __ ]
entre vire ils ont fait un carton aux
dons via non tu trahis tout proche viril
à new yok et voilages ans et afin de
céder 2 / chivalry d'eliès myers un jeu
j'apprécie beaucoup parce que le
gameplay est vraiment marrant ça court
partout ça se tape partout et c'est
vraiment rigolo même si décrit comme ça
ça n'appelle tous les rigolos n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu c'est un
grand plaisir à sa femme grand plaisir
aux sandales de spartiates
on se retrouve très vite de nouvelles
vidéos tient tout le monde ici